it may look like a washout but finally
they have the run of the road 5,000
cyclists have joined this nighttime ride
through Moscow unthinkable during the
day and a unique experience for fans of
two wheels which tool is meyonce a lot
has changed on the streets of Moscow
things are being done and that's great
that's a revulsion at the cursor on
sounds you do I hope it'll get even
better at the moment it's just about
okay the authorities have set up 30 bike
rental stations the first half hour is
free of charge and there are new stands
for locking up bikes although many
remain unused this is the man behind the
revolution it's the job of alexeiev to
come up with a new cycling strategy for
Moscow I got fed up of driving through
all the traffic so in a way my work
benefits me personally if there's
something I don't like I try to change
it like with the infrastructure yes
there's a new Frisco wide boulevards
clogged with automobiles are a familiar
part of daily life in Moscow cyclists
are still few and far between they have
to contend with a lack of bike lanes
and underpasses that slow progress and
make Moscow even more challenging to
navigate on two wheels little wonder
that uptake is poor for the new bike
rental service even though it's been
designed for convenience after
registering online users simply pick up
a bike when they need one I need
previous on these bikes are limited to a
specific area but I can go anywhere I
want by car that's the problem what's
your problem ok swear you'll see people
here have an erratic style of driving
that's a big danger to us cyclists
produced at the Bolshoi Rosa Alex eamonn
TF has been advocating cyclists rights
for many years now it's his job to
convince more muscovites to ditch their
four wheels for 20 delicious nuts the
water by 2016 we want 0.1 percent of all
journeys made in Moscow to be by bike
today it's point zero zero zero zero
zero something percent like an SH
Whitson easiest nakia it's an ambitious
goal but Alex yeh hopes that soon more
moscow cyclists will be heading in the
right direction